ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב השם שלי הוא John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני
לחינוך ב-IBM Quantum זה השיעור ה-11 בסדרה וזה השיעור השלישי ביחידה
השלישית שעוסקת בניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי השיעור הזה הוא על מדידות שמייצגות
ממשק בין מידע קוונטי לקלאסי כשמבצעים מדידה על מערכת בזמן שהיא במצב
קוונטי מידע קלאסי מופק וחושף משהו על המצב הקוונטי הזה ובדרך כלל משנה או
הורס את המצב הזה בתהליך בניסוח מפושט של מידע קוונטי שנדון
ביחידה הראשונה של הסדרה בדרך כלל אנחנו מגבילים את תשומת הלב שלנו למדידות הטלה כולל
הסוג הפשוט ביותר של מדידה מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי אבל אפשר להכליל את המושג של מדידה
וזה מתברר כדבר די שימושי לעשות בשיעור הזה נדבר על מדידות בכלליות מלאה
כולל איך הן מתוארות במונחים מתמטיים ואיך הן משתלבות בניסוח הכללי של מידע
קוונטי לקראת סוף השיעור גם נסתכל על כמה מושגים בסיסיים שקשורים למדידות והם הבחנת מצב קוונטי
וטומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי אז בואו נתחיל הנה סקירה של
השיעור כמו שאנחנו עושים הרבה פעמים נתחיל מהיסודות כולל כמה דרכים שונות אבל שקולות שבהן אנחנו
יכולים לתאר מדידות במונחים מתמטיים בפרט אנחנו יכולים לתאר מדידות באמצעות אוספים של מטריצות
ואנחנו יכולים גם לתאר אותן כערוצים שרמזתי עליהם בשיעור הקודם נדון גם במדידות
חלקיות או במילים אחרות מדידות שמבוצעות רק על חלק אחד של מערכת מורכבת
גדולה יותר אחר כך נעבור למשפט ניימרק שהוא עובדה בסיסית לגבי מדידות שבעצם
אומרת שמדידות כלליות תמיד אפשר לממש בצורה פשוטה שמזכירה ייצוגי Stinespring
של ערוצים בקיצור מדידות כלליות תמיד אפשר לממש על ידי הכנסה של מערכת
עבודה מאותחלת ביצוע פעולה אוניטרית ולבסוף ביצוע מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי
על מערכת העבודה זה מתברר כדי קל להוכחה ונראה איך זה הולך ו
גם נראה איך זה מתחבר למה שנקרא מדידות לא-הרסניות שאני אתאר לבסוף בחלק האחרון של
השיעור נדון בהבחנת מצב קוונטי וטומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי נתחיל עם תיאורים מתמטיים
של מדידות מדידות מספקות לנו ממשק בין מידע קוונטי
לקלאסי כשמבצעים מדידה על מערכת בזמן שהיא באיזשהו מצב קוונטי מידע קלאסי
על המצב הקוונטי הזה מופק בנוסף המצב הקוונטי בדרך כלל משתנה או אולי
נהרס לחלוטין בהתחלה נתמקד במה שנקרא מדידות הרסניות שבהן
מצב קוונטי נכנס ורק מידע קלאסי יוצא אז אין שום ציון של
המצב הקוונטי שאחרי המדידה של המערכת שנמדדה אינטואיטיבית אפשר לדמיין שמדידה הרסנית
הורסת את כל המערכת שנמדדה אז המצב שלה אחרי שהמדידה מתבצעת לא
מצוין זה לא אומר שמכשירים פיזיים בהכרח נהרסים זה רק תיאור מתמטי
וזה תיאור מאוד שימושי כי הוא עוזר לשמור על דברים פשוטים ולהתמקד בהיבטים המתמטיים
המהותיים של מדידות יש בפרט שתי דרכים שקולות לתאר מדידות
הרסניות שהזכרתי בסקירה של השיעור דרך אחת לתאר מדידה
הרסנית היא באמצעות אוסף של מטריצות שבפרט יש לנו מטריצה אחת לכל תוצאת מדידה אפשרית
דרך שנייה לתאר מדידה הרסנית היא באמצעות ערוץ שבו
הקלט הוא המצב של כל מערכת שנמדדת והפלט הוא תמיד מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית שאנחנו יכולים
לפרש כתיאור של התפלגות הסתברות על תוצאות המדידה הקלאסיות
האפשריות שני התיאורים שקולים וזה די שימושי כי זה מאפשר לנו לבחור את התיאור הנוח יותר ב
מצב נתון נדבר גם על מדידות לא-הרסניות שבהן בנוסף לתוצאת מדידה קלאסית
המצב הקוונטי שאחרי המדידה של המערכת שנמדדה גם
מצוין מדידות לא-הרסניות חשובות והן מופיעות הרבה אבל יש מובן שבו הן
איכשהו פחות בסיסיות ממדידות הרסניות במונחים מתמטיים בפרט כפי שמתברר
מדידות לא-הרסניות תמיד אפשר לתאר כהרכבות של ערוצים ומדידות הרסניות ו
נראה איך זה עובד קצת מאוחר יותר בשיעור עכשיו בואו נסתכל על איך מדידות כלומר מדידות
הרסניות אפשר לתאר כאוספים של מטריצות לאורך כל הדיון נניח ש-X היא מערכת ש
נמדדת ורק בשביל הפשטות נעשה כמה הנחות ראשית נניח שקבוצת
המצבים הקלאסית של X מורכבת מהמספרים השלמים מ-0 עד n פחות אחד עבור מספר שלם חיובי כלשהו n והתוצאות
האפשריות של המדידה הן המספרים השלמים מ-0 עד M פחות אחד שוב עבור מספר שלם חיובי כלשהו M לא צריך
להיות שום קשר בין המספרים n ו-M שניהם מספרים שלמים חיוביים שרירותיים וכמובן אפשר להחליף
את הקבוצות האלה בקבוצות מצבים קלאסיות שרירותיות אם רוצים ראשית בואו ניזכר איך מדידות
הטלה עובדות שדיברנו עליהן לראשונה בשיעור השלישי של הסדרה בהנחה ש
תוצאות המדידה הן המספרים השלמים מ-0 עד n פחות אחד אנחנו מתארים מדידת הטלה באמצעות אוסף
של הטלות פאי 0 עד פאי M פחות אחד שסכומן הוא מטריצת היחידה והמטריצות האלה כולן עם שורות ו
עמודות שמתאימות למצבים הקלאסיים של X או במילים אחרות אלה כולן מטריצות n כפול n
אם X במצב קוונטי שמתואר על ידי וקטור מצב קוונטי s אז כל תוצאת מדידה אפשרית
a מופיעה בהסתברות שווה לנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע של פאי a כפול
הוקטור s הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע של כל וקטור שווה למכפלה הפנימית של אותו
וקטור עם עצמו אז מקבלים את הביטוי שמוצג על המסך ואפשר לפשט את זה קצת
על ידי שימוש בעובדה שפאי a היא הטלה אז כפל שלה בעצמה לא עושה
כלום ולבסוף אפשר לכתוב מחדש את הביטוי שקיבלנו בצורה קצת שונה באמצעות התכונה המחזורית
של העקבה שוב כמו שמוצג על המסך ואם לא ברור למה אנחנו רוצים לכתוב את הביטוי ככה התשובה
הקצרה היא שאנחנו רוצים להבין איך מדידות הטלה עובדות עבור מטריצות
צפיפות ובפרט על ידי לינאריות אנחנו מקבלים שאם המצב של X מתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו ולא
וקטור מצב קוונטי s אז ההסתברות שתוצאה a תופיע ניתנת על ידי העקבה של ההטלה
פאי a כפול מטריצת הצפיפות רו זה חייב להיות ככה כי כמו שראינו
תמיד אפשר לחשוב על מטריצת צפיפות כממוצע משוקלל של מצבים טהורים ואם מממצעים את
ההסתברויות המתאימות מקבלים את הביטוי הזה כי העקבה היא פונקציה לינארית אז זה הביטוי שאנחנו
שואפים אליו ואפשר לסדר את הדברים קצת כדי להתמקד במטריצות
צפיפות הנקודה העיקרית של לעשות את זה אגב היא לקבוע נקודת ייחוס למה שכבר למדנו
ולראות שהתיאור הזה של מדידות הטלה הוא בעצם מקרה פרטי של תיאור יותר כללי של מדידות שאנחנו
עומדים לראות אז מה שאעשה עכשיו זה להחליף את התיאור הזה של איך מדידות הטלה עובדות עבור מטריצות צפיפות
בתיאור של מדידות כלליות כדי שנוכל להבין את הקשר והנה
זה מדידה כללית לא בהכרח מדידת הטלה מתוארת על ידי אוסף של מטריצות חיוביות
למחצה p 0 עד PM פחות אחד שסכומן הוא מטריצת היחידה ואם מבצעים את המדידה הזו על X בזמן שהיא
במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו אז כל תוצאה a מופיעה בהסתברות שווה לעקבה של PA כפול
רו בקיצור הדבר היחיד שהשתנה הוא שהקלנו את התנאי על המטריצות האלה בפרט המטריצות
לא צריכות להיות מטריצות הטלה הן רק צריכות להיות חיוביות למחצה ובהתאם החלפתי את האות פאי באות p
כי פאי זה שם מקובל להטלה בעוד שאני מעדיף להשתמש באות P למטריצות חיוביות
למחצה זוהי הכללה של התיאור שהיה לנו למדידות הטלה אגב כי מטריצות הטלה תמיד חיוביות
למחצה ובעצם אפשר להגדיר אותן לחלופין כמטריצות חיוביות למחצה שהערכים העצמיים שלהן
יכולים להיות רק אפס ואחד אפשר לראות שההגדרה הזו
הגיונית בכך שתמיד מקבלים וקטור הסתברות עבור הסתברויות התוצאות באופן
הבא ראשית המספרים האלה שקראתי להם הסתברויות תוצאה הם תמיד מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים זה
בגלל שגם PA וגם רו הם חיוביים למחצה והעקבה של המכפלה של שתי מטריצות חיוביות
למחצה היא תמיד מספר ממשי אי-שלילי ואשאיר לכם לחשוב למה זה
ככה ושנית המספרים חייבים להסתכם לאחד כי העקבה היא לינארית ו
המטריצות p 0 עד pN פחות אחד נדרשות להסתכם למטריצת היחידה ולמטריצות צפיפות יש עקבה שווה ל
אחד אז ללא קשר לאיזו מטריצת צפיפות רו התחלנו איתה הסתברויות התוצאה אכן תמיד יהוו
וקטור הסתברות עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות כבר הזכרתי ש
מדידות הטלה הן מקרה פרטי של מדידות כלליות כי הטלות תמיד חיוביות למחצה
אבל נחמד להתחיל פשוט אז בואו נתחיל עם מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי של qubit אפשר לייצג מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי
של qubit בשתי מטריצות p 0 ו-P1 שמוגדרות כמו שמוצג על המסך p 0 זה z בְּרָא אפס ו-P1 זה k1
בְּרָא אחד אלה שתיהן מטריצות חיוביות למחצה ובעצם הן הטלות והן ברור מסתכמות למטריצת
היחידה אז ביחד הן מתארות מדידה אם מפעילים את המדידה הזו על qubit
במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו אז ההסתברות שתוצאה אפס תופיע היא העקבה של p 0 כפול רו
וההסתברות לתוצאה אחד היא העקבה של P1 כפול רו ועל ידי התכונה המחזורית של העקבה מקבלים
את שני האיברים האלכסוניים של רו כפי שמצופה הנה דוגמה נוספת שבה הפעם
המטריצות הן לא הטלות הן כן חיוביות למחצה וכן הן מטריצות
צפיפות אבל זה לא חשוב מה שכן חשוב הוא שהן מסתכמות למטריצת היחידה אז ביחד הן מתארות
מדידה אפשר לראות מה קורה כשמבצעים את המדידה הזו על qubit במצב פלוס למשל רק כדי
לראות איך זה עובד עבור דוגמה אחת של מצב וחישוב של ההסתברויות מוצג על
המסך שימו לב בפרט שלמרות שמצב הפלוס הוא מצב טהור ואנחנו יכולים לייצג את המצב הזה בוקטור מצב קוונטי קט פלוס אנחנו צריכים
לחבר את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות של המצב הזה שזה קט פלוס בְּרָא פלוס לתוך הנוסחאות כדי לקבל
את ההסתברויות ובואו גם אציין שבגלל שאנחנו מדברים על מדידה הרסנית אין שום
ציון של המצב הקוונטי שאחרי המדידה של ה-qubit הזה אז כל מה שיש לנו זה ציון של הסתברויות
התוצאה הנה דוגמה אחרונה לעת עתה והיא די מעניינת שוב זו מדידה של
qubit בודד וכדי לתאר אותה נתחיל בהגדרת ארבעה וקטורי מצב קוונטי הידועים כמצבים
הטטרהדרליים והסיבה שהם נקראים מצבים טטרהדרליים היא שהם מתאימים לארבעת הקודקודים של
טטרהדר רגולרי חסום בתוך כדור בלוך ולהבהיר כשאנחנו אומרים שזה טטרהדר רגולרי
הכוונה היא גוף מרובע שכל אחד מהפאות שלו הוא משולש שווה צלעות אז יש כאן סימטריה מושלמת כל
צלע באותו אורך ואותה זווית נוצרת בין כל שתי צלעות
סמוכות ועכשיו אפשר להגדיר מדידה מעניינת עם ארבע תוצאות אפשריות כמו שמוצג על המסך או במילים אפשר לקחת את
המטריצות שלנו כייצוגי מטריצת הצפיפות של המצבים האלה חלקי שתיים עכשיו אלה בהחלט מטריצות חיוביות
למחצה כי הן מטריצות צפיפות חלקי שתיים ואפשר לעבור על החשבון כדי לבדוק
שהן אכן מסתכמות למטריצת היחידה אבל דרך אחרת לראות את זה היא לחשוב על הסימטריה אם מממצעים את ארבעת המצבים האלה
ביחד מקבלים את המצב המעורב לחלוטין שנמצא במרכז כדור בלוך אבל כי אנחנו מחלקים
כל אחד בשתיים ולא בארבע מקבלים פעמיים את המצב המעורב לחלוטין שזה מטריצת היחידה לא אגיד יותר על
המדידה הזו כרגע חוץ מלציין שהיא לא מדידת הטלה אבל היא דוגמה נחמדה ו
נראה אותה שוב מאוחר יותר בשיעור דרך נוספת לתאר מדידות כלליות היא כערוצים כמו שנדון
עכשיו הרעיון כאן הוא שמצבים הסתברותיים קלאסיים אפשר לייצג על ידי מטריצות צפיפות אלכסוניות ולכן
כי תוצאות מדידה הן קלאסיות אפשר לחשוב על מדידות כערוצים שבהם הפלט הוא תמיד מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית
שמתארת את תוצאת המדידה אז בואו נסתכל על זה קצת יותר לעומק אם חושבים
באופן מופשט על מדידה כללית אפשר לתאר את המדידה הזו כערוץ פי מערכת הקלט של הערוץ היא
כל מערכת X שנמדדת ומערכת הפלט היא מערכת y שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה מתאימים ל
תוצאות המדידה שאנחנו מניחים שהן המספרים השלמים מ-0 עד n פחות אחד עבור מספר שלם חיובי
כלשהו M וכי תוצאות מדידה הן קלאסיות אנחנו דורשים שעבור כל מטריצת צפיפות קלט רו של המערכת
X הפלט פי של רו חייב להיות מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית למשל אם חושבים על
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי של qubit וחושבים על המדידה הזו כמתוארת על ידי ערוץ אפשר לבטא את זה כמו שיש לנו כאן על המסך
אם מטריצת הצפיפות של הקלט היא רו אז נקבל את תוצאה אפס בהסתברות שווה לבְּרָא 0 רו קט אפס
ונקבל את תוצאה אחד בהסתברות בְּרָא אחד רו קט אחד ואם מבטאים את תוצאות המדידה הקלאסיות
האלה כמטריצות צפיפות נקבל את הביטוי הזה עבור הערוץ המתאים ומתברר
שזה לא אחר מאשר ערוץ ההפרדה המוחלט וזה עקבי עם הרעיון שערוץ ההפרדה המוחלט
מייצג צורה קיצונית של דה-קוהרנציה שיכולה להיות בעלת משמעויות שונות אבל כשאני משתמש במונח הזה אני
מדבר על הנטייה של מצבים קוונטיים להפוך לקלאסיים כי הסביבה מסביב לכל מערכת שעליה אנחנו
מדברים צופה במובן מסוים או במילים אחרות היא מודדת
אז תוצאות מדידה אפשר לתאר כערוצים כמו שתיארתי אבל זו לא רק אפשרות זה
אפיון של מדידות כלליות ומה שאני מתכוון בזה הוא הדבר הבא כמובן יש ערוצים
שלא מייצגים מדידות כי הפלט לא תמיד מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית אבל אם כן
המקרה שהפלט של ערוץ הוא תמיד מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית ללא קשר לאיזה מצב קלט רו שנבחר אז בהכרח אפשר
לבטא את הערוץ הזה בצורה שמוצגת על המסך עבור בחירה כלשהי של מדידה כלומר אוסף של
מטריצות חיוביות למחצה שמסתכמות למטריצת היחידה וזה נחמד מכמה סיבות כולל העובדה שזה
בעצם אומר לנו שההגדרה שלנו של מדידות כאוספים של מטריצות לא מפספסת
כלום דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שהדרך הזו לחשוב על מדידות כערוצים היא אופרציונלית
או אקסיומטית אולי במובן שהיא תופסת מה מדידה צריכה להיות שזה תהליך פיזי ש
הופך מידע קוונטי למידע קלאסי ומתברר שזה לגמרי שקול לתיאור הראשון
שלנו של מדידות שהוא אלגברי לחלוטין לא אעבור על ההוכחה של השקילות בסרטון הזה אבל היא
לא קשה ואם אתם מעוניינים אפשר למצוא את ההוכחה בחומר הכתוב של השיעור שמקושר בתיאור הסרטון
דיברנו על מה קורה כשמבצעים מדידה כללית על מערכת במצב נתון
לפחות עבור המקרה של מדידות הרסניות אחר כך נדבר על מדידות חלקיות כלומר ש
רק חלק אחד של מערכת מורכבת נמדד בואו נניח בדיוק שיש לנו זוג מערכות XZ ש
ביחד נמצאות במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו ומדידה שמתוארת על ידי אוסף של מטריצות חיוביות למחצה שמסתכמות ל
מטריצת היחידה מבוצעת על המערכת X לבד טבעי שזה מוביל ל
תוצאת מדידה וכי אנחנו מדברים על מדידות הרסניות אפשר לדמיין שתהליך המדידה הורס את המערכת
X אבל עדיין יש לנו את המערכת Z לדאוג לה ואנחנו צריכים להבין איך המדידה של X משפיעה על המצב
של Z ראשית בואו נדבר על הסתברויות
התוצאה כי אנחנו מדברים על מדידה של המערכת X לבד ההסתברויות לתוצאות שונות
להופיע יכולות לתלות רק במצב של X בבידוד כלומר הן יכולות לתלות רק ב
מצב המצומצם של X בפרט ההסתברות שתוצאה נתונה a תופיע ניתנת על ידי
אותה נוסחה מקודם שהיא העקבה של PA כפול המצב המצומצם של X שאנחנו מסמנים ברו
תת X המצב רו תת X מתקבל מרו על ידי עקיבה של Z אז אפשר לעשות את
ההצבה הזו ולמרות שזה אולי לא מיד ברור הביטוי שמקבלים אפשר לכתוב גם כמו שמוצג
על המסך זה העקבה של PA טנזור מטריצת היחידה על המערכת Z כפול
רו עכשיו זו שוויון שבהחלט שווה לקחת זמן לאמת אותו זה אינטואיטיבי אנחנו לא עושים
כלום ל-Z אז הגיוני שמטריצת היחידה על Z תופיע ככה אבל אפשר גם לאמת את זה
אלגברית ואשאיר את זה לכם יחד עם ההצעה לשקול קודם את המקרה שרו הוא מכפלה טנזורית של שתי מטריצות ואז
להשתמש בלינאריות כדי להסיק שזה חייב לעבוד לכל רו וגם אגיד שזה לא תלוי בעובדה ש-PA
היא חיובית למחצה או שרו היא מטריצת צפיפות זה שוויון שיעבוד לכל בחירה של
מטריצות במקום PA ורו כל עוד יש להן את הממדים הנכונים כדי שהביטוי יהיה
הגיוני ועכשיו בואו נראה איך המצב של Z מושפע מהמדידה והגישה הטבעית מ
בחינתי היא לחשוב על המדידה כערוץ הנה הערוץ שאנחנו משייכים למדידה שלנו ואנחנו
חושבים על זה כערוץ מהמערכת X למערכת חדשה y שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה מתאימים לתוצאות המדידה אז בנוסחה הזו
סיגמא מייצגת מצב של המערכת X לבד אם מפעילים את הערוץ הזה על
המערכת X בזמן שהזוג XZ במצב רו אז נקבל את מטריצת הצפיפות שיש לנו כאן שוב
קחו כמה זמן שצריך כדי לאמת את זה ושוב ההצעה שלי היא קודם לשקול את המקרה שרו היא מכפלה
טנזורית של שתי מטריצות ואז להשתמש בלינאריות עכשיו ראינו את סוג המצב הזה
שבו המערכת הראשונה היא קלאסית והמערכת השנייה היא קוונטית כדוגמה בשיעור על מטריצות
הצפיפות כל a מופיע באיזושהי הסתברות וזו העקבה של הגורם הטנזורי השני אז אפשר לחשוב
על הגורמים הטנזוריים השניים האלה כמטריצות צפיפות מוכפלות בהסתברויות אז כדי לקבל את המצב של
Z בתנאי שמקבלים תוצאת מדידה מסוימת a פשוט מחלקים את ההסתברות או במילים אחרות אנחנו
מנרמלים את הגורם הטנזורי השני על ידי חלוקה בעקבה שלו עצמו אז לסיכום אם מבצעים
מדידה על X בזמן שהזוג XZ במצב רו ככה זה עובד ראשית כל תוצאה a מופיעה
בהסתברות שווה לעקבה של PA טנזור מטריצת היחידה כפול רו ושנית בתנאי שמקבלים
תוצאת מדידה מסוימת a המצב של Z ניתן על ידי הביטוי שמוצג על המסך שזה מה שמקבלים
על ידי נרמול המטריצה שראינו לפני רגע וזה אותו דבר כמו לחלק את המטריצה בהסתברות
ש-a יופיע צריך לציין שזה הגיוני רק אם ההסתברות היא לא אפס כי אחרת אנחנו
מחלקים באפס אבל זה בסדר כי אנחנו לא צריכים לדאוג לדברים שלא קורים בחלק הזה של
השיעור נדון במשפט פשוט אבל בסיסי על מדידות שנקרא משפט
ניימרק בקיצור מה שהוא אומר הוא שכל מדידה אפשר לממש כמו שהאיור על המסך
מציע אם נשים את זה במילים מדידה כללית נתונה על מערכת X אפשר לממש באופן הבא
קודם מכניסים מערכת עבודה מאותחלת y שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה הם תוצאות המדידה האפשריות שאנחנו מניחים שממוספרות
מ-0 עד n פחות אחד אז מבצעים פעולה אוניטרית U על הזוג
YX ואז מבצעים מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי על y אז בעצם הכל קבוע
כאן חוץ מהבחירה של U ומה שהמשפט אומר הוא שאכן אפשר לבחור את הפעולה האוניטרית
U כך שההסתברויות לתוצאות השונות תמיד יתאימו למדידה הכללית הנתונה
עכשיו בואו נראה איך מוכיחים את משפט ניימרק וזה לא קשה אנחנו רק צריכים לעשות בחירה טובה של
הפעולה האוניטרית U ולוודא שזה עובד אבל קודם אנחנו צריכים עובדה בסיסית
מתורת המטריצות שהיא שלכל מטריצה חיובית למחצה P תמיד קיימת מטריצה חיובית למחצה
יחידה Q כזו ש-Q בריבוע שווה ל-P באופן כללי יכולות להיות הרבה מטריצות שבריבוע נותנות לנו P אבל
תמיד יש בדיוק אחת שהיא חיובית למחצה הסימון שאנחנו משתמשים בו לציין את המטריצה הזו הוא שורש ריבועי של
P וככה גם אנחנו מתייחסים אליה במילים אם רוצים לחשב את השורש הריבועי של P עבור מטריצה
חיובית למחצה P אגב אפשר לעשות את זה על ידי חישוב פירוק ספקטרלי של P ואז
להחליף כל אחד מהערכים העצמיים בשורש הריבועי שלו ולהשאיר את הוקטורים העצמיים כמו שהם הערכים העצמיים כולם אי-
שליליים אז זה הגיוני ודי קל לראות שהמטריצה שמקבלים היא אכן חיובית למחצה
ובריבוע נותנת P העובדה שהיא יחידה זה עניין אחר לא קשה
להוכיח את זה באמצעות כמה עובדות בסיסיות על מטריצות אבל זה קצת משני לשיעור ופשוט ניקח את החלק הזה
כנתון ועכשיו שיש לנו את המושג הזה ביד די קל לציין
פעולה אוניטרית U שעובדת כל מטריצה אוניטרית שמתאימה לדפוס שמוצג על המסך תעבוד בעצם
n העמודות הראשונות בהנחה ש-X יש n מצבים קלאסיים כמו קודם מתקבלות על ידי ערימת השורשים הריבועיים של
המטריצות שמתארות את המדידה אחד מעל השני ושאר העמודות יכולות להיות מה שנרצה
זה לא משנה כל עוד המטריצה כולה אוניטרית
ואגב אם אתם שמים לב לדמיון בין זה לחיבור בין ייצוגי Kraus ו-Stinespring של ערוצים זה לא מקרי ו
בעצם מה שיש לנו כאן הוא בעצם מקרה פרטי של זה שבו מטריצות Kraus שלנו במקרה חיוביות
למחצה אז יש שני דברים שצריך לבדוק הראשון הוא שהבחירה הזו של U באמת עובדת ו
השני הוא שאפשר לבחור את העמודות הלא מוגדרות בצורה שהופכת את U לאוניטרית אז בואו נתחיל עם הראשון
הנה המצב שבו מתחילים המערכת התחתונה Y מאותחלת למצב אפס בעוד שהמערכת העליונה
מתחילה במצב רו ואז מבצעים U שאומר שמצמידים ב-
U אפשר לכתוב את הכל במונחים של מטריצות בלוקים כמו שמוצג על המסך יש U בצד שמאל U דאגר בצד
ימין וקט אפס בְּרָא אפס טנזור רו באמצע שלובש את הצורה שיש כאן כאשר יש רו ב
פינה שמאלית עליונה ואפסים בכל מקום אחר ואם חושבים על המכפלה הזו לרגע ברור ש
האיברים הלא מוגדרים של U בכלל לא משנים כי הם תמיד מוכפלים באיברי אפס של
המטריצה שבאמצע ואם מבצעים את הכפל מקבלים את
המטריצה שמוצגת כאן שמתוארת כמטריצת בלוקים או לחלופין אפשר לבטא אותה באמצעות סימון דירק
ככה זו בעצם הצורה הנוחה יותר עבורנו אז בואו נתמקד בביטוי
הזה ולצורך הנוחות בואו ניתן למטריצה הזו שהיא מטריצת צפיפות את השם
סיגמא הצעד האחרון הוא מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי על y אז בואו נחשב את המצב המצומצם ב-y ו
זה קל בהינתן הביטוי שיש לנו פשוט עוקבים את X שמתאים לגורם הטנזורי
השני אז ההסתברות שתוצאה נתונה a תופיע היא האיבר האלכסוני שמתאים ל-a אפשר לכתוב
את זה ככה וזה שווה לעקבה של שורש PA כפול רו כפול שורש
PA ועל ידי התכונה המחזורית של העקבה מקבלים את העקבה של PA כפול רו
שזה מה שקיווינו לקבל אז ההסתברויות לתוצאות השונות להופיע נכונות הן תמיד מתאימות
למדידה המקורית שהתחלנו ממנה הדבר השני שצריך לבדוק
הוא שאפשר למלא את העמודות הלא מוגדרות של U בצורה שהופכת אותה
לאוניטרית זה נובע מהעובדה שn העמודות הראשונות שהן אלה שנוצרות מהשורשים הריבועיים של המטריצות שמתארות את
המדידה הן אורתונורמליות וזה אפשר לבדוק ישירות הפרטים הרלוונטיים כאן
על המסך אז עצרו את הסרטון וקחו כמה רגעים לחשוב על זה אם תרצו אבל כמו שהצעתי קודם
זה בעצם מקרה פרטי של משהו שפגשנו בשיעור הקודם וזו
ההוכחה עד כה בשיעור שמרנו את המיקוד שלנו על מדידות הרסניות כלומר שאין ציון של
המצב הקוונטי שאחרי המדידה של המערכת שנמדדה עבור מדידה לא-הרסנית לעומת זאת יש
לא רק תוצאת מדידה קלאסית אלא גם מצב קוונטי שאחרי המדידה של המערכת שנמדדה ו
כפי שנראה יש חיבור טבעי למשפט ניימרק יש בעצם דרכים שונות לנסח מדידות
לא-הרסניות במונחים מתמטיים אבל נתחיל עם ניסוח אחד שבעצם מגיע ישירות ממשפט
ניימרק נתבונן במדידה כללית כלומר הרסנית שמתוארת על ידי אוסף של מטריצות חיוביות
למחצה p 0 עד pN פחות אחד שמסתכמות למטריצת היחידה אפשר אז להפוך את
המדידה הזו למדידה לא-הרסנית פשוט על ידי התבוננות במימוש של המדידה הזו שדנו בו בהקשר של משפט
ניימרק מכניסים מערכת חדשה y מבצעים עליה אינטראקציה עם X דרך פעולה אוניטרית U ואז מבצעים מדידת בסיס
סטנדרטי על y אז המערכת X עדיין שם ואנחנו יכולים להתבונן במצב
שלה ועל סמך הניתוח שעברנו אפשר לקבוע שמצב X שאחרי המדידה בתנאי
שמקבלים תוצאת מדידה מסוימת a ניתן על ידי מטריצת צפיפות שנראית
ככה במילים מצמידים על ידי השורש הריבועי של מטריצת המדידה המתאימה ואז
מנרמלים דרך אחרת לנסח מדידות לא-הרסניות שהיא יותר כללית היא במונחים של מטריצות Kraus
של ערוצים וזו ההגדרה של מדידות שתמצאו בספר הלימוד המוכר של Nielsen
ו-Chuang למשל נניח ש-m0 עד m M פחות אחד הן מטריצות ריבועיות שמקיימות
את המשוואה שמוצגת על המסך כלומר אפשר לחשוב על המטריצות האלה כמטריצות Kraus שמתארות
ערוץ בעצם המטריצות האלה מתארות ערוץ אבל הן גם מתארות מדידה לא-הרסנית
והדרך שבה זה עובד כשמודדים מערכת במצב נתון רו היא ראשית הסתברויות התוצאה
ניתנות על ידי המשוואה שמוצגת על המסך כל תוצאה מופיעה בהסתברות שווה לעקבה של ma כפול
רו כפול ma דאגר ובתנאי שתוצאה a מופיעה המצב של המערכת שנמדדה
נראה ככה מדידות לא-הרסניות מסוג זה אפשר לממש ב
צורה דומה למה שהיה לנו במשפט ניימרק ואשאיר לכם לחשוב על זה אם
תבחרו אפשר להכליל את המושג של מדידה לא-הרסנית אפילו יותר מזה למשל
יש מושג שנקרא אינסטרומנט קוונטי שלפעמים די שימושי אבל לא אכסה את זה בסרטון
הזה בחלק האחרון של השיעור אדבר בקצרה על שתי משימות שקשורות למדידות הבחנת מצב קוונטי וטומוגרפיה של מצב
קוונטי יש הרבה מה לומר על שני המושגים האלה ואנחנו באמת רק מגרדים את
פני השטח אז בואו נתחיל בהבהרה למה המונחים האלה מתייחסים ובמה הם שונים
ראשון הוא הבחנת מצב קוונטי הרעיון כאן הוא שיש לנו אוסף ידוע של מצבים
קוונטיים של מערכת כלשהי יחד עם הסתברויות שמשויכות למצבים האלה אז בואו נניח במדויק
שרו 0 עד רו M פחות אחד הן מטריצות צפיפות שמייצגות מצבים קוונטיים אפשריים של מערכת X ו-p 0
עד pN פחות אחד הן הסתברויות שמשויכות למצבים האלה אז אם אוספים את ההסתברויות לוקטור
בודד מקבלים וקטור הסתברות דרך תמציתית לומר את זה אגב היא שיש לנו אנסמבל של מצבים
קוונטיים ועכשיו דרך מופשטת שבה אפשר לחשוב על הבחנת מצב קוונטי כמשימה או כבעיה
היא שקודם נבחר מספר בין אפס ל-N פחות אחד באופן אקראי לפי ההסתברויות המערכת X אז
מוכנה במצב שמתאים למספר שנבחר באקראי והמטרה היא לקבוע באמצעות
מדידה של X איזה מספר נבחר אז יש לנו מספר סופי של
חלופות יחד עם אפריורי והמטרה היא לקבוע איזו חלופה באמת קרתה עבור בחירות מסוימות של מצבים ו
הסתברויות זה עשוי להיות קל ועבור אחרות אולי לא יהיה אפשר לעשות את זה בלי סיכוי מסוים לטעות
ויש שאלות ספציפיות שונות שאפשר לשאול כמו מה ההסתברות המינימלית לטעות
ואיך נראית מדידה שמשיגה את ההסתברות המינימלית הזו לטעות טומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי לעומת
זאת היא שונה כאן יש לנו מצב קוונטי לא ידוע של מערכת אז
בדרך כלל אין אפריורי או מידע על חלופות אפשריות הפעם אבל לא עותק יחיד של המצב עומד
לרשותנו אלא הרבה עותקים בלתי תלויים עומדים לרשותנו כלומר עבור מספר אולי גדול
n יש לנו n מערכות זהות X1 עד xn שכל אחת מוכנה באופן בלתי תלוי במצב
רו והפעם המטרה היא למצוא קירוב של המצב הקוונטי הלא ידוע הזה כמטריצת צפיפות על ידי מדידה של
המערכות אז לסיכום בהבחנת מצב קוונטי יש לנו עותק בודד של
המצב ואנחנו מנסים להבחין בין מספר סופי של חלופות ידועות ובטומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי יש לנו הרבה עותקים בלתי תלויים
של מצב קוונטי לא ידוע והמטרה היא למצוא תיאור של המצב הזה או לפחות קירוב סביר
שלו הבחנת מצב קוונטי מעניינת כי היא מפשטת סוג של מצב שנוצר בדרך כלל ב
חישוב וקריפטוגרפיה למשל שבו חלופה אחת מתוך קבוצה סופית של אפשרויות התרחשה ואנחנו או מישהו אחר מנסים
לגלות איזו אחת היא על ידי מדידה של מערכת קוונטית המקרה הפשוט ביותר הלא-טריוויאלי הוא
כשיש רק שתי חלופות כלומר ש-M שווה לשתיים אז המשימה היא להבחין בין זוג
מצבים המקרה הזה מתברר כבעיה שנפתרה לחלוטין בהנחה שהמטרה היא למזער
את הסיכוי להבחנה שגויה יש בחירה אופטימלית למדידה והיא נקראת לעתים קרובות
מדידת Helstrom זו מדידת הטלה בעצם ואפשר לתאר אותה
כך קודם מתבוננים בהפרש המשוקלל בין שתי החלופות כלומר p 0 כפול רו 0 פחות P1 כפול רו אחד
אז מכפילים את ההסתברות לשלוף כל אחד משני המצבים האלה במצבים עצמם ולוקחים את
ההפרש זו מטריצה הרמיטית כי היא שווה לצמוד שלה אז יש לה פירוק
ספקטרלי ואנחנו יודעים בפרט שהערכים העצמיים הם כולם מספרים ממשיים אז בואו נניח שיש לנו
פירוק ספקטרלי כתוב בצורה שמוצגת על המסך מה שעושים אחר כך הוא לאסוף את
הערכים העצמיים לשתי קבוצות כאשר כל הערכים העצמיים החיוביים בקבוצה אחת וכל הערכים העצמיים השליליים ב
אחרת ליתר דיוק בואו ניקח s0 כקבוצת כל האינדקסים k שעבורם הערך העצמי המתאים למבדא K הוא
אי-שלילי ו-S1 שאר האינדקסים שהם אלה שמתאימים לערכים עצמיים שליליים
בעצם לא משנה איזו קבוצה מכילה את האינדקסים שמתאימים לערכים עצמיים שהם אפס כאן אנחנו עושים
בחירה שרירותית לכלול אותם ב-s0 אבל לא היה משנה אם חלקם או כולם היו נכללים ב-S1 במקום מה שבאמת חשוב הוא
שאנחנו מפרידים בין הערכים העצמיים החיוביים והשליליים ולבסוף מגדירים שתי הטלות פאי
0 ופאי 1 כמו שמוצג על המסך במילים פאי 0 היא ההטלה על
תת-המרחב הנפרש על ידי הוקטורים העצמיים שמתאימים לערכים עצמיים אי-שליליים ופאי 1 היא ההטלה על המרחב
הנפרש על ידי הוקטורים העצמיים שמתאימים לערכים עצמיים שליליים אלה אכן הטלות ו
אם מחברים אותן ביחד מקבלים את מטריצת היחידה כי הוקטורים העצמיים s 0 עד s N פחות אחד יוצרים
בסיס אורתונורמלי אם מבצעים את המדידה הזו במצב הנדון כלומר
שהמצב הנמדד הוא רו 0 בהסתברות p 0 ורו אחד בהסתברות P1 אז מתברר
שלהסתברות של זיהוי נכון יש נוסחה די פשוטה במונחים של הערכים העצמיים למבדא 0 עד למבדא n פחות
אחד לא אעבור על הפרטים של החישוב בסרטון הזה אפשר להיעזר בתוכן הכתוב שמקושר בתיאור הסרטון אם אתם
מעוניינים או לנסות לשכנע את עצמכם שהנוסחה הזו אכן נכונה אפשר גם לבטא את
ההסתברות הזו באמצעות נורמת מטריצה שנקראת בדרך כלל נורמת העקבה זה סימון דומה לנורמה האוקלידית לוקטורים
חוץ מזה שיש כתב תחתון של אחד כדי לציין שזו נורמת העקבה נורמת העקבה מאוד חשובה ו
נתקלים בה הרבה מאוד בחישוב קוונטי אבל לא אגיד הרבה יותר עליה בשיעור הזה דרך אחת
להגדיר אותה למטריצות הרמיטיות היא שהיא סכום הערכים המוחלטים של הערכים העצמיים ואז אפשר לחשוב
על השוויון השני הזה כנובע ישירות מההגדרה הזו אפשר להגדיר את נורמת העקבה גם
בדרכים אחרות שהן יותר כלליות ונפגוש את נורמת העקבה שוב בשיעור הבא זה בעצם
הכי טוב שאפשר לעשות המדידה הזו אופטימלית בהנחה שהמטרה היא למקסם את הסיכוי לניחוש
נכון העובדה הזו נקראת לפעמים משפט Helstrom-Holevo ולפעמים היא נקראת פשוט משפט
Helstrom אז אי אפשר לנצח את המדידה הזו מבחינת הסתברות הנכונות וזה נחמד כי
יש מתכון פשוט למדידה עצמה ונוסחה מדויקת להסתברות הנכונות במונחים של נורמת
העקבה נורמת העקבה משמשת הרבה פעמים כדרך למדוד את ההבדל הנצפה בין מטריצות צפיפות מ
בדיוק הסיבה הזו וכשאנשים מתייחסים למרחק העקבה בין מצבים הם בדרך כלל מתכוונים ל
חצי כפול נורמת העקבה של ההפרש בין שתי מטריצות הצפיפות שכאן מתאים למקרה ש-p 0 ו-P1 שניהם חצי שזה
מקרה טבעי לשקול הבחנת מצב קוונטי לשני מצבים נפתרת בצורה אופטימלית על ידי
מדידת Helstrom שעבורה יש מתכון פשוט ונוסחה פשוטה להסתברות
הנכונות אז מה קורה כשרוצים להבחין בין שלושה מצבים או יותר במקרה הזה אין לנו
נוסחה כללית לבחירה אופטימלית של מדידה או ביטוי פשוט להסתברות המקסימלית של
נכונות אבל כן אפשר למצוא קירוב טוב למדידה אופטימלית בעזרת מחשב
ובפרט אפשר לעשות את זה באמצעות טכניקת אופטימיזציה מרתקת וחזקה שנקראת תכנות חצי-מוגדר אבל זה לא
משהו שאפשר לממש באופן ריאלי עם עיפרון ודף נייר למשל מצד שני אם מישהו
נותן לכם תיאור של מדידה וטוען שהמדידה הזו אופטימלית למשימת הבחנת מצב קוונטי אז זה
באמת מאוד קל לאמת או להפריך את הטענה הזו וזה אפשר לעשות באמצעות מה שנקרא תנאי Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax לא אסביר מה הם בסרטון הזה אבל הם תנאים פשוטים ודי מגניב
שזה אפשרי הנה דוגמה שמתחברת חזרה למצבים הטטרהדרליים
שראינו מוקדם יותר בשיעור נניח שמקבלים אחד מארבעת המצבים האלה שנבחר באקראי עם
הסתברות רבע לכל אחד והמטרה שלנו היא לקבוע איזה מצב קיבלנו אולי זה לא מפתיע אבל
הבחירה הטובה ביותר שאפשר לעשות למדידה בשביל זה היא המדידה הטטרהדרלית לא תמיד אפשר לעשות
משהו כזה עבור אוסף שרירותי של מצבים טהורים אבל בגלל הסימטריות שמעורבות כאן זה כן
עובד ובאמת מקבלים מדידה תקפה ודרך תנאי Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax שהזכרתי
לפני כמה רגעים מתברר שדי פשוט להוכיח שזו אכן בחירה אופטימלית של
מדידה ספציפית מה שקורה כאן הוא שהמדידה תמיד נכונה בהסתברות חצי שזה לא
רע כי יש ארבע חלופות אז ההסתברות לניחוש נכון טובה פי שניים מניחוש אקראי ו
במקרה זה הכי טוב שאפשר לעשות עם המצבים האלה עכשיו אגיד עוד קצת על טומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי
שבה יש לנו הרבה עותקים בלתי תלויים של מצב קוונטי לא ידוע והמטרה היא למצוא קירוב של מטריצת הצפיפות שמתארת
את המצב הזה יש בעצם כמה וריאנטים שונים של הבעיה הזו שתלויים בהנחות שלכם וב
פרט באילו סוגי מדידות מותרים למשל אפשר לדרוש שכל מערכת נמדדת בנפרד ו
התוצאות משולבות איכשהו כדי להגיע לתיאור של מטריצת הצפיפות או שאפשר לאפשר לכל
המערכות להימדד ביחד כמערכת מורכבת אחת שזה הרבה יותר טוב בתיאוריה אבל גם הרבה יותר
תובעני מבחינה טכנולוגית בנוסף לבחירות שעושים למדידות יש
גם שיקול חשוב שהוא איך לשחזר תיאור של מטריצת הצפיפות מכל נתון ש
מקבלים מהמדידות לא איכנס לפרטים הנקודה שלי היא פשוט להציע
שטומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי היא באמת יותר מושג מטריה שיש לו הרבה וריאנטים שונים ולא
פרוצדורה אחת היה הרבה מחקר לגבי הבעיה הזו כולל כמה תוצאות
פריצת דרך שהתגלו לאחרונה שמקשרות בין מספר העותקים n לדיוק של הקירוב שאפשר להשיג וזה ממשיך להיות תחום
מחקר מעניין ופעיל כדי לסיים את השיעור בואו נסתכל על טומוגרפיה של מצב קוונטי
עבור qubit ואיך אפשר לעשות את זה אז בואו נניח שרו היא מטריצת צפיפות שמייצגת מצב של
qubit בודד ו-X1 עד xn הם qubit שכולם הוכנו באופן בלתי תלוי במצב רו ולצורך
הדיון הזה בואו נניח ש-n גדול מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לחלק את
המערכות לשלוש ערימות בערך שוות ועבור הערימה הראשונה נבצע מדידה ביחס לבסיס
פלוס-מינוס עבור כל תוצאה שמתאימה לפלוס נרשום פלוס אחד ועבור כל
תוצאה שמתאימה למינוס נרשום מינוס אחד דרך תמציתית יותר לתאר את המדידה
הזו היא שזו מדידת Pauli X כי מצבי הפלוס והמינוס הם וקטורים עצמיים של מטריצת Pauli X ו
הערכים העצמיים המתאימים הם פלוס אחד ומינוס אחד ובעצם זו גם דרך הרבה יותר נפוצה לתאר את זה ו
אכן התוחלת של הציון שווה לעקבה של סיגמא x כפול רו עכשיו אנחנו לא בהכרח לומדים מה
התוחלת הזו אבל אם מממצעים את הציונים שמקבלים על פני הרבה מאוד ניסויים סביר שנקבל
קירוב סביר לתוחלת הזו על פי חוק המספרים הגדולים ויש כמה חסמים סטטיסטיים ידועים שאפשר להפעיל
על זה אם רוצים להיות יותר כמותיים לגבי האמירה הזו עושים משהו דומה עם סיגמא y על השליש השני של
המערכות הדבר היחיד שמשתנה כאן הוא שמשתמשים במצבי פלוס i ומינוס i שהם וקטורים עצמיים של סיגמא
Y ובאופן דומה עבור סיגמא Z שעבורה וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי הם וקטורים
עצמיים ואז לבסוף אפשר להשתמש בנוסחה שמוצגת על המסך שאומרת לנו מה המקדמים צריכים להיות
אם רו כתובה כצירוף לינארי של מטריצות Pauli ועל ידי הצבת הקירובים שלנו למקדמים האלה
ואולי התאמה קטנה שלהם כדי לוודא שמקבלים מטריצה חיובית למחצה מקבלים קירוב ל
רו כמובן יש פרטים שלא נכנסתי אליהם כמו הדיוק של הקירוב ומידת
הביטחון שאפשר לקוות לה אבל בתקווה זה נותן לכם רעיון בסיסי של דרך אחת שבה אפשר לבצע טומוגרפיה על
qubit אפשר גם לבצע טומוגרפיה של qubit באמצעות המדידה הטטרהדרלית ובעצם זה מתברר
כדי פשוט ואלגנטי לפחות במונחים מתמטיים מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לבצע רק
את המדידה הזו לבד על כל העותקים הבלתי תלויים של המצב הקוונטי הלא ידוע שלנו ועל ידי שימוש ב
נוסחה המדהימה שמוצגת כאן אפשר להגיע לקירוב של המצב שלנו על ידי אומדן של העקבה של PK כפול
רו לכל K על ידי שבר הפעמים שתוצאת המדידה המתאימה מופיעה שוב זה עובד רק בגלל
הסימטריות המושלמות שיש לנו בין ארבעת המצבים האלה ויש בעצם כמה בעיות פתוחות ממש מרתקות שקשורות להכללות
של הגישה הזו למערכות גדולות יותר וזה מקום טוב לעצור את השיעור תודה שצפיתם ואני
מקווה שתצטרפו אליי לשיעור הבא שעוסק בטיהורים ונאמנות להתראות